[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver avec Olivier vivorka pour une
histoire totale de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale chez pin avec la collaboration
du ministère des armées Olivier bonjour
tout le monde se en tout cas ceux qui se
passionnent pour l'histoire tout le tout
monde sait que vous êtes un des grands
spécialistes mondiaux de cette seconde
guerre mondiale d'où une histoire totale
tous les continents sauf l'Amérique
évidemment qui a été épargé tous les
détails vous trouvvez ça dans ce livre
qui est un véritable événement et il se
trouve que pour la même émission avec
Jean-Luc Barray qui est à la fois
romancier qui est à la fois biographe et
qui est en même temps éditeur de l'd des
éditions bouquin et bien nous sommes
face à une autre somme des années de
travail l'homme de personne c'est le
premier tome de trois tomes d'une
biographie donc du général de Gaulle
nous allons plonger euh dans deux
époques qui se croisent vous le savez à
savoir la carrière du général de Gaulle
et puis cette fameuse Seconde Guerre
mondiale qui raisonne en nous
actuellement il suffit de connaître les
déclarations de Vladimir Poutine de voir
ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient vous
dites d'ailleurs et je vais commencer
par Jean-Luc mais en faisant un petit
détour par vous Olivier que la grande
question qui est posée c'est d'ailleurs
à vous deux que je la que j'adresse et
qui est celle de ces deux livres c'est
qu'au fond l'homme que nous sommes les
hommes que nous sommes hommes et femmes
quand on est confronté à ce genre de
situation la question fondamentale c'est
de savoir si on doit se soumettre ou si
on doit se démettre et se révolter et
c'est la question qui est posée à
travers des massacres fondamentaux qui
ont quand même entaché cette moitié du
du 20e siècle quelle est la réponse que
vous donnez après avoir autant
travailler Olivier bien écoutez oui vous
avez entièrement raison je pense que la
Seconde Guerre mondiale a posé au aux
hommes et aux femmes de l'époque des
questions qui étaient à la fois
existentielle et essentielle dans la
mesure où la Seconde Guerre mondiale ne
ressemble pas à la première en fait les
individus ont été soumis à à des
pressions extrêmement fortes la guerre
et la violence de guerre mais aussi ne
l'oublions pas l'occupation et ne
l'oublions pas la dictature et ces trois
éléments ont placé et les exterminations
et les exterminations et les individus
ont été placés donc devant des choix à
la fois existentiels et essentiels parce
que chacun avait au fond une marge de
manœuvre pour savoir si il était du côté
des bourreaux ou du côté des héros et en
même temps ces choix engageaient la vie
des individ
et c'est pour C je crois aussi la
Seconde Guerre mondiale nous parle
beaucoup plus que la prière où
l'éventail des choéventil des possibles
était beaucoup plus limité pendant le
premier conflit voilà la Seconde Guerre
mondiale n'a pas redessiné évidemment le
profil de la plupart des États du monde
je disais l'Amérique a été épargné nous
allons en parler dans un instant avec
Olivier dans la famille De Gaulle
Jean-Luc Barret donc bonjour l'homme de
personne 1890 1944 il est dans une rue
qui porte un nom magnifique la rue
Princesse son appartement enfin cette
maison a dispar paru ils n'ont jamais
été capable de l'acheter son père
s'appelait Henry c'était un personnage
d'une droiture extrême sa mère était
très catholique une enfance très
heureuse dans cette rue Princesse et
puis très rapidement à une parce que
c'est une biographie à une
représentation de l'Aiglon il a 10 ans
il dit à son père je serai soldat oui
c'est enfin la dimension du théâtre est
très importante hein si on veut
comprendre de Gaulle et dans la famille
on jouit on jouit du théâtre on jouit on
jouit Corneil on jouit racine et et je
crois qu'il a inventé déjà son
personnage comme ça bon et et c'est pas
par hasard que c'est au théâtre en effet
une représentation de l'iglon avec Sarah
Bernard et il dit à son père je veux
être soldat donc tout démarre au fond
par l'aspect de dramaturgie un peu
épique et il écrit lui-même alors il
écrit pas pas une très bonne pièce mais
il écrit dans il est en fait c'est un
homme de théâtre qui va toujours être
aussi dans la composition d'un rôle le
rôle c'est c'est de GA il va créer ce
personnage au fond quand il parle de lui
à la trème personne c'est pas une preuve
d'orgueil c'est simplement que c'est
comme une espèce de grand acteur qui se
protège qui se projetterait dans un
personnage qu'il a lui-même créé voilà
ce personnage ce sera une duplication du
Cano de bergorac par exemple il fait une
sorte de parodie de rant absolument euh
et de parodie de la tirade du nez euh il
a une dizaine d'années euh il s'investit
considérablement dans cette idée de la
carrière des armes c'est un personnage
qui avec les les les ses
contemporains sa stature son allure son
comportement est largement différent des
autres immédiatement y compris en
famille y compris en famille d'ailleurs
il est pas il est pas l'aîné mais il
prend la tête de la famille euh euh il
est parfois même désagréable avec ses
frères je donne un exemple quand ils
sont ensemble dans un collège où il
raconte à son père ce que ne fait pas
son frère pour les études et cetera donc
il est il est assez arrogant il est le
fils préféré de sa mère et et le père
est très inquiet de ce que pourrait
devenir son fils extraordinaire
tellement le le fils est singulier au
fond et est très original et il a une
une forme d'obsession c'est de devenir
un jour un soldat enfin il aurait pu
devenir aussi un écrivain il aurait pu
devenir un professeur ça faisait partie
des des éventualités mais le être soldat
c'était réparé aussi la blessure du père
le père n'avait jamais pu faire une
carrière militaire à cause de la guerre
de 70 et parce que les moyens financiers
manquaient donc c'est un presque un
geste réparateur mais à l'époque il est
obsédé comme toute cette génération par
l'idée de la revanche et au fond la
grande carrière le grand idéal c'est
quand même d'être un soldat et un jour
de venger finalement la France Jean-Luc
Rabar ce que vous racontez avec beaucoup
d'intérêt c'est que de GA est à la fois
un homme extraordinairement brillant un
jeune homme il lit énormément des
philosophes des écrivains bon les
grandes idoles vous parliez de Corneille
mais c'est château brillants il liber il
s'intéresse à la philosophie allemande
par le biais de son père qui devient
enseignant très marqué par
l'enseignement des Jésuites pas très
comment dirais-je proche de ce grand
mouvement de la République des har noir
de la République mais le paradoxe c'est
que il passe son bac il obtient pas une
note exceptionnelle il entre à saint-cir
il obtient pas une note exceptionnelle
donc si vous voulez vous nous décrivez
une sorte de de génie en train d'avancer
mais que finalement l'université de
l'époque si on peut dire sanctionne
d'une manière moyenne oui alors ce qui
caractérise de Gaulle c'est c'est
l'intelligence mais c'est d'abord le
caractère quand on lit le fil de l'épée
il dit que c'est d'abord le caractère
qui compte plus que l'intelligence au
fond c'est un homme de caractère qui a
du mal à s'adapter au milieu dans
lesquel il est parce que il aime pas for
saincire c'est pas forcément quelque
chose un univers qu'il aime l'université
il travaillera bien parce qu'il va
finire 13e oui voilà mais en fait il est
pas il est moins classé que le futur
maréchal Juin
et ça ça ça c'est pas forcément ce qui
lui importe le plus c'est d'être c'est
d'exister c'est d'affirmer soit des
idées soit d'affirmer un caractère avec
cette idée quand même d'un destin qui
est en lui bon et ce destin il va
commencer par leexercer à haras et là
première coïncidence évidemment
incroyable il arrive à ras comme jeune
sousoficier on a passé beaucoup de
choses dans cette affaire mais c'est
justement le charme inoui de ces deux
livres de voyez j'ai j'ai pris un nom
uncalculable de je peux même plus les
relire tellement chaque page est
passionnant à haras il retombe et il
tombe sur Pétin c'est que le patron du
régiment où il va c'est le maréchal
celui qui n'est pas encore maréchal mais
c'est Pétin qui dirige oui alors juste
une précision il va il est pas à race
par hasard il a le choix entre la
coloniale et l'infanterie et il choisit
ce que peu d'officiers à ce moment-là
choisissent parce que c'est plus ingrat
c'est la c'est c'est l'infanterie
c'estàdire de rester en en métropole
parce qu'il pens que c'est là évidemment
que là va se jouer le sort de la France
et là il rencontre Pétin qui est un
personnage à l'époque qui finalement il
y a beaucoup de similitudes entre eux
parce que Pétin est une sorte
d'anticonformiste à l'époque c'est un
personnage un peu iconoclaste il est pas
il va il va devenir général parce que la
grande guerre va éclater mais il a
beaucoup de mal à progresser dans la
hiérarchie on TR jeis donner un détail
qui explique quand même ce sont deux
hommes qui sont très passionnés par la
logistique et très critique à l'égard
d'un mouvement de guerre qui se fait
beaucoup à l'époque en gros je parle
tout contrôle d'Olivier parce qu'
évidemment j'ai peur c'estd l'assaut
absolu le le la la la version presque
traditionnelle la cavalerie la
chevalerie et cetera on se rue ver les
ça c'est de Gaul ça voilà et et et et ça
Pétin est totalement hostile à ça et
d'une certaine manière de Gaulle verra
comme jeune soldat parce qu'il est il
est pendant la guerre blessé 3 qu fois
euh il verra quelle absurdité il y a à
se rouer euh sur les lignes ennemis
alors que la logistique n'est absolument
pas préparée oui mais mais ça ça c'est
un état d'esprit c'est presque une
philosophie de l'action chez De Gaulle
il voit les limites effectivement de sa
propre vision il n'empêche que ça sera
toujours son idée que l'offensive doit
primer dans dans dans l'action militaire
là où la guerre d'usure pour pour
schématiser résumé et plutôt la
philosophie de de Pétin d'ailleurs sa
gloire viendra du fait qu'il a été
économe de ces hommes contrairement à
d'autres hein qui qui évidemment était
de véritable bouché donc mais ces deux
philosophies de la vie au fond ces deux
philosophies qu'on va retrouver dans les
années 30 entre celui qui va prenner une
défense pour le coup offensive moderne
et cetera et un homme qui va se ugier
derrière une vision plus traditionnelle
ils se retrouveront après la guerre
puisque de Gaul va travailler pour Pétin
ce qui est quand même absolument
invraisemblable quand on entre dans le
détail de ça après évidemment avoir
connu les relations qui seront et leur
opposition fondamentale au nom du destin
de la France petit à petit évidemment il
va s'intéresser à la choses publiqu
publier des livres parler de l'état de
l'armée de française ça nous ramène
puisquon a commencé en 70 par cette idée
quand même qu'il existe en France che
certains personnages éclairés une
incurie totale de l'état-major une
incurie totale de la culture politique
des hommes qui nous dirigent c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il va rejoindre un
cabinet et commencer à jouer un rôle
politique avant de partir pour Londres
qui est un endroit dit ellisabeth
deibell qui a été sa correspondante
peut-être aussi son amie en tout cas
celle qui fut sa confidente Londres qui
était une ville dont on partait et non
pas d'une ville dans laquelle on voulait
se rendre vous écrivez ça très bien dans
votre livre Olivier vivorka l'histoire
totale de la Seconde Guerre mondiale je
précise puisque vous avez déjà une envie
prodigieuse de lire ces deux livres que
nous allons revenir évidemment sur la
sur la la guerre au moment où elle va se
déclencher avec nos deux amis mais qui
implique évidemment la France dans cette
affaire là mais là nous allons faire la
guerre mondiale la guerre que vous
appelez totale tous les continents sont
concernés et j'ai plusieurs questions
précises à vous poser d'entrée la
première concerne évidemment le décembre
41 pe Harbor qui est le tournant des
tournants puisque vous racontez et l'un
et l'autre que Churchill puis de Gaulle
qui est avec le colonel Passi écoute à
la radio ce qui se passe et l'un et
l'autre disent puisque les Américains
vont rentrer en guerre cette fois-ci la
guerre a basculé le nazisme s'est
terminé donc on est le 7 décembre le 7
ou 8 décembre voilà 41 mais alors
question Olivier quand vous voyez partir
du Japon une escadre avec si porteavion
des cuurassés des droyers 400 avions euh
des des des sous-marins de poche et ce
comment se fait-il que les Américains au
matin il y a eu des films se réveillent
sans se se rendre compte de ce qu'il va
leur tomber dessus alors vous avez
raison de souligner ce point parce que
vous avez eu toute une théorie
complotiste qui affirmait que Roosevelt
en fait était au courant et qu' aurait
laissé au fond l'irréparable se
commettre pour obliger les concitoyens
ces concitoyens américains à entrer en
guerre en fait c'est malheureusement
comme souvent en histoire une suite
d'erreur une suite de mauvaise
interprétation par exemple lorsque les
les premiers appareils sont en vue de
Perre l'arbor et bien ils sont repérés
par des radars auquels à l'époque les
Américains ne c pas archipel archipel
d'hawaiï donc archipel d'hawaiï et euh
au fond il croit que ce sont des B17 des
des bombardiers qui reviennent au
berkaaille et donc il n'y prêtent pas
attention enfin c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable mais c'est ainsi c'est
l'armée japonaise c'est l'armée
impériale qui retombe dessus oui mais
vous avez également et c'est ce qui
explique cette méconnaissance ou en tous
les cas cet aveuglement vous avez un
solide mépris pour les Japonais qui est
un mépris n'hésitons pas à le dire
raciste qui fait que aucun Américain
n'imagine que euh les Japonais puissent
monter une opération aussi sophisé quand
on traverse 5000 km comme ça ça ça
n'avance pas à la vitesse de la lumière
un porte-avion comment se fait-il qu'il
n'y a pas la moindre je dire information
qui soit tombée du côté de l'état-major
parce que vous décrivez Roosevelt comme
quelqu'un contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qui est
totalement abattu par la nouvelle tout à
fait il est abattu au départ et ensuite
il euh il devient euh résolu mais euh
euh nous n'avons pas non plus il faut le
souligner euh les moyens techniques HM
euh qui existent aujourd'hui euh vous
évoquez per l'arbor mais lors que les
Anglo-Américains lancent l'opération
torche en novembre 1942 cette opération
torche il s'agit oui pour débarquer en
Afrique du Nord et bien les Allemands ne
la repèent pas immédiatement ils la
repèrent et ensuite ils commettent une
erreur d'appréciation en pensant que les
convois se dirigent plutôt euh vers
Malte vers la Libye vers l'Égypte et non
pas vers le Maroc et l'Algérie donc vous
vous avez vous n'avez pas les moyens
techniques de repérer euh nécessairement
des armanas et ensuite vous même si vous
les repérez vous n'avez pas
nécessairement la capacité à interpréter
le sens que revesse euh que que que
revêent ses voyages euh ce que raconte
ce livre est absolument effrayant euh
c'est-à-dire que vous décrivez la peur
c'est les soldats qui ont la bouche
noire de peur euh vous donnerz un des
exemples dans les batailles du Pacifique
qu'on connaît un peu moins Ivo Jima une
petite île 21 km carré vous pouvez
imaginer alors il faut rappeler que les
Japonais sont en guerre contre les
Chinois et que leur idée c'est
évidemment de prendre le contrôle de
l'Asie et le contrôle du Pacifique de
manière à pouvoir se réapprovisionner et
pouvoir assumer cette guerre donc ils
nont pas du tout l'intention d'aller
planter le drapeon impérial à Washington
ils veulent simplement s'assurer car
vous le dites depuis le début la grande
caractéristique de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'est que c'est une guerre
d'infrastructure une guerre industrielle
et qu'il est pas tout à fait anormal que
les Américains et les Russes a finit par
l'emporter car ce sont les deux grandes
industries qui l'ont qui qui dominaient
le monde à l'époque je vais de surprise
en surprise je vais à ivojima 21 km² 76
jours de bombardement tous les Japonais
péris ils sont plus de 20000 les 2/ers
les Américains périssent pour 21 km²
d'une petite île dans le Pacifique la
violence des combats vous en parle elle
est absolument éorissante je dis
violence des combats et violence des
massacres stalingrade une horreur course
une horreur la forêt des ardenes une
horreur les les soldats claquent des
dents vous le racontez mais c'est
important de de le RPP
les massacres sont multiples quand les
Croix Fléchées je je je raconte un peu
votre fille parce que ça m'a bouleversé
quand les Croix Fléchées sont les
fchistes Hongrois prennent le pouvoir
avant même que Budapest ne tombe en 45
ils vont massacrer combien 10 20 30000
juifs qui avaient échappé à la
déportation comme ça en quelques heures
tout à fait parce qu'en fait vous avez
dans cette dans cette guerre à la fois
une violence de guerre qui dirait close
vit conduit à une ascension aux extrêmes
c'est-à-dire que au fond toutes les
barrières morales sautent on n'hésite
pas à bombarder on nésiteag résonance de
ce que vous dites dans ce qu'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui bien endu
bien entendu ensuite vous avez une
violence qui est la violence raciste qui
conduit à la Choa mais qui conduit aussi
les Japonais à ne pas faire de quartier
vous l'avez rappelé avec les les Chinois
et puis vous avez une violence de
l'exploitation économique qui conduit à
la servitude alors en Europe nous avons
bien entendu le service du travail
obligatoire et ce n'était pas très drôle
de travailler en en Allemagne à
forcierie sous les bombes mais la
violence de l'exploitation économique
que les Japonais imposent en Asie est
extrême on en a d'ailleurs une une
illustration avec le film le pont de la
rivière k donc tous ces éléments si vous
voulez vont aboutir à des massacres
énormes et des massacres dont il faut le
souligner les civils sont beaucoup plus
victimes que les militaair sur les 60 et
70 millions de morts il y a
essentiellement des civils euh plus de
25 millions de Russes les Russes n'ont
pas été les derniers bien inquiétant
après avoir signé le PACT
germano-soviétique évidemment il y a
l'opération Barbarossa et il se
précipite faire Berlin alors eux leur
stratégie c'est de contourner
l'Allemagne et de passer par les pays de
l'Europe orientale où là ont lieu des
viols des vols enfin des des situations
qui sont apocalyptique et c'est pour ça
que le livre est passionnant et très
complémentaire de celui de de de
Jean-Luc Barret question concernant la
France car on va avoir des conversations
avec Jean-Luc et avec vous sur le rôle
de de Gaul et les grands hommes
finalement de cet épisode exceptionnel
vous me dites moi qui étais un petit
professeur d'histoire qu'en fait
l'étatmajor moi j'avais toujours pensé
que les Allemands ils étaient passés par
la Belgique et puis le problème de la
France était réglé c'est vrai que ça a
été une débacle terrible mais ils s sont
pris à 30 foid oui tout à fait parce que
moi j'avais l'impression qu'ils avaient
pris la décision que c'était réglé après
la Pologne non il faut d'abord rappeler
que l'entrée en guerre du Royaume-Uni
d'abord et de la France ensuite a été
une mauvaise nouvelle pour Hitler il ne
faut pas imaginer que Hitler déroule un
plan inscrit dans mcampf par exemple au
départ il ne comptait pas attaquer la
Pologne donc ça il faut le souligner et
par rapport à à ses plans il va
effectivement hésiter parce qu'il a un
étatmajor qui au fond adopte une vue
tout à fait classique c'est-à-dire
entrer par la Belgique et c'est parce
que toutes ces offensives sont ajournées
que Hitler va tendre une oreille
attentive à ce que lui propose un
stratège mstein qui lui dit il va
falloir frapper là où le dispositif
français plus faible à savoir dans les
Ardennes et là on va percer et réduire
l'armée française à néant et c'est ce
plan que Hitler va choisir c'est ce que
l'on a appelé donc la Blitz CREG qui en
fait n'est pas une idée théorisée exanté
Hitler ne se dit pas je vais faire la
Blitz CREG c'est en fait un plan qui est
un petit peu un plan du dernier espoir
et qui va effectivement fonctionner il
fonctionne en France alors qu'il n'a pas
été théorisé en revanche en Russie il
est théorisé hitire pense obtenir la
décision rapidement mais grâce à Dieu il
échoue il y a aussi les mythes et
légendes de cette histoire je vais
prendre quelques exemples avant que nous
démarrions la conversation générale sur
Churchill de Gaul isenower enfin les
grands personnages qui ont marqué cette
période évidemment Staline Roosevelt
c'est quelques mythes Romel Montgomery
par exemple Montgomery a toujours été le
grand officier britannique et cetera
vous nous raconter qu'à cand pour la
libération de C après le débarquement il
n' pas été très bon que quand il était
en Belgique et qu'il a fallu aller en
Bavière très rapidement il a laissé
échapper pratiquement 100000 hommes
allemands parce qu'il a voulu faire une
pause et que ça a été une catastrophe et
que donc la bataille pour la reconquête
de l'Allemagne a été très compliquée
pour une raison qui est fondamentale
c'est que quand Munich intervient Dadier
Chamberlin Hitler et cetera il n'y a pas
simplement cette déception qui a lieu
évidemment chez Dadier quand il rentre
en France et qui dit au fond les
Français ne comprendnent rien à ce qui
se passe il y a aussi le fait que
champberdin est applaudi par par les
Allemands c'estàd que les Allemands
sachant que Hitler veut faire la guerre
sont quand même encore au moment où la
guerre commence pacifiste oui vous avez
entièrement raison de le souligner les
Allemands ne veulent pas la guerre et on
le voit et à la fin ils sont déchînés
oui parce que au fond cette guerre ils
ne la veulent pas mais ils sont prêtes à
la faire parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
que la guerre de 1418 s'est mal terminée
et que on va leur imposer un conflit et
que ce conflit il faut relever le gant
donc c'est ce qui explique que les
Allemands soient au fond résigné à faire
la guerre ils la font sans enthousiasme
mais ils la font mais à partir du moment
où vous avez cette grande croisade
contre le bolchevisme renaet au fond
l'idée non seulement d'encerclement mais
de menace existentielle pour l'Allemagne
l'idée que l'Allemagne va disparaître
submergée par l'Est et un est au village
peu amè puisque c'est un un un est
communiste donc vous avez euh au fond un
impensé de la seconde guerre mondial qui
en fait reste très présent à la fois au
niveau de la réflexion des dirigeants hm
hm dans le2e siècle mais également dans
la mémoire des individus parce que le
conflit a été si radical si total si
puissant que nous ortons tous dans une
certaine mesure la marque encore
incandescente ou les familles qui sont
là aujourd'hui et qui ont un grand-père
qui a participé justement à ses assaut à
ces massacres car ils ont été importants
question Jean-Luc Barret on parle aux
grands hommes comment se fait-il que
l'un les plus grands poètes français
saint-jn persce Alexis Saint-Léger donc
qui a été pendant très longtemps le
directeur du ké d'orset et qui était à
New York euh comment se fait-il qu'il
ait fait une campagne quand même assez
violente anti de Gaulle auprès des
Américains et auprès de Roosevelt car
vous avez en Afrique du Nord Giro et
d'arland de Gaul plaident auprès de
chill en disant c'est moi qui su le
représentant de la France et plein de
gens le débinent oui enfin saint-jun
persce qui s'appelle Alexis léger en
fait comme diplomate est aussi
responsable de ce qui s'est passé
l'échec de la diplomatie française dans
les années 30 il en est un des
responsables euh donc c'est un homme qui
pour le coup n'a pas une vision il a une
vision essentiellement pacifiste
d'ailleurs de des problèmes à ce
moment-là le rapport avec de Gaul est
impossible avec beaucoup de ces gens-là
parce qu'au fond c'est un militaire il
ne supporte pas cette idée-là ils
pensent que de Gaul est un nationaliste
avant tout et peut-être même une sorte
d'apprenti dictateur et donc il ne
correspond pas au code républicain
finalement qui sont ceux de saintjon
perce mais il va très loin saint-jon
perce en effet et il va alimenter
l'antigolisme de de Roosevelt Washington
à Washington sans doute c'est le plus
plus influent plus que jean-My encore et
et au fond il il ne se réconsilia jamais
avec de Gaulle c'est c'est d'ailleurs la
question qui va se poser pendant toute
cette période c'est le nombre de gens de
de de valeur de de grande qualité qui
vont se défier de De Gaulle ce qui bien
que de Gaulle à l'OND sera entouré de
tout le reste si je puis dire de parfois
de personnages très
secondaires mais
mais là on parle des Anglais mais des
Français eux-mêmes il n'aura pas tout de
suite mais même à la Libération
d'ailleurs parfois il y aura même une
pénurie de de de ministre de dirigeant
de qualité parce que beaucoup de gens
non ont refusé de le rejoindre au nom de
ces idéesl d'ailleurs et au nom de cette
défiance je reviens à vous Olivier parce
qu'il faut il faut enfin ce qui est
intéressant quand on confonte ces deux
livres qui sont absolument passionnants
c'est que dans l'histoire totale
finalement l'histoire de France après la
défaite et le début B elle est minime
dans le destin qui se passe dans le
monde entier on a joué un rôle mineur
dans cette affair là oui alors la France
a joué un rôle mineur un rôle mineur
cela ne veut pas dire un rôle
négligeable d'une parce que la France
est un enjeu tant pour l'axe que pour
les Alliés n'oublions pas que la France
va fournir une contribution économique
par exemple extrêmement importante au
reche par ailleurs il faut souligner que
la France elle a un empire et que cet
empire va être un enjeu un enjeu non
seulement géopolitique des bases mais un
enjeu économique et un enjeu
démographique l'armée qui va contribuer
d'une part à libérer l'Italie et de
l'autre à libérer la France c'est une
armée pour reprendre la formule
consacrée d'indigène de la République
très largement vous raconter au passage
je redonne sur ces statistique j'adore
allire dans le détail c'est que les
soldat qui font la campagne d'Italie
pour la mort c'est 10 % c'est qu'ils
sont à 10 % certains de mourir et à 30 %
certains d'être blessés mutilés donc
c'est une véritable horreur la guerre en
Italie a été une guerre atroce et c'est
une guerre qui a été portée
effectivement par les goumiers par par
les tirailleurs sénégalais et cetera et
puis l'Empire va fournir aussi des
ressources en caoutchu en or d'abord à
Vichi et ensuite à la France combattante
puis au CFLN donc la France a joué un
rôle mineur mais elle n'a pas joué un
rôle
négligeable dernier point qui est
important là je suis obligé de retrouver
mes notes pour pouvoir poser cette
question c'est
évidemment les bombes atomiques
Hiroshima Nagasaki nous sommes vous le
savez en 45 c'est le 6 et le 9 que ces
deux bombes vont tomber il n pas été
possible d' tenir les Japonais une
réédition il a fallu donc que ces de
bombes atomiques soient largué ce qui
est une attrocité absolue et qui nous
pose encore un problème aujourd'hui oui
alors dans le même temps il faut bien
insister sur un point c'est que ce son
c'est que ce ne sont pas les bombes
atomiques qui provoquent la
réditionition du Japon vous avez bien
entendu ces deux bombes qui jouent un
rôle mais ce qui va jouer un rôle encore
plus important c'est l'offensive que
déclenche l'Armée rouge l'empereur est
donc confronté un dilemme est-ce que il
faut accepter une occupation soviétique
ou une occupation américaine je vous
laisse deviner son choix alors il est
vrai que à partir de 1945 on va entrer
dans un autre régime militaire
stratégique diplomatique régie par
l'atome mais à l'époque en 1945 ces
bombes elles ont été utilisées de
manière classique comme en fait des
bombes super puissantes mais dont
l'essence n'était pas différente tout ce
qui va être ensuite équilibre de la
terreur euh destruction mutuelle assurée
ripost gradué ne viendra qu' après et de
ce point de vue donc Hiroshima et
Nagasaki c'est à la fois une aurore et
un crépuscule un crépuscule parce que au
fond ça clos la Seconde Guerre mondiale
avec je le répète l'intervention de de
l'Armée rouge mais c'est aussi une
aurore parce que l'on va changer de
dimension du point de vue stratégique et
géopolitique avec bien évidemment cette
menace nucléaire qui désormais pèse sur
la planète Jean-Luc Barret évidemment le
cœur de ce livre famille qui démarre en
70 famille qui doute de ce qu'est la vie
politique famille qui doute de ce
que'est l'étatmajor famille qui va
donner donc à la France son plus grand
homme du 20e siècle est-ce que c'est
votre conviction profonde et est-ce que
de de Gaul il n'y aura plus non je pense
qu'il y a pas eu de de Gaul avant il a
entre Napoléon de Gaulle il y a eu
clémeno mais c'est tout donc je veux
dire c'est des personnages tout à fait
exceptionnels qui ont qui ont surtout
moi ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'esttre
ce qui j'ai la chose qui a été par que
arriv oui non mais c'est la vision
c'estd qu'on a on l'a beaucoup enferm
mais dans le pragmatisme de Gaulle en
disant l'homme des circonstances c'est
un mot qu' emploie beaucoup la vision
comment cet homme arrive à construire
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
question allemande et russes lors d'une
conférence en 1920 en Pologne il annonce
l'alliance entre les les les les Russes
et et les allemand il dit il dit au
Polonais vous êtes sans doute le seul
rempart possible il est très lucide hein
sur ce que peut faire la Pologne donc
l'intuition la vision et ça c'est
quelque chose d'absolument fascinant
parce que c'est c'est très rare au fond
dans l'histoire aujourd'hui on ne vit
plus que dans l'actualité on ne vit pas
dans l'histoire je sais pas s'il y aura
pas d'autres de Gaulle demain ce que je
vois aujourd'hui c'est qu'en tout cas on
on a plus d'homme de vision je voudrais
signaler le livre d'Antony bivor Calman
Levy Russie révolution et Guer civil il
c'est vous le connaissez évidemment
autre grand historien il raconte la
prise du pouvoir par les bolcheviques
c'est très simple les bolcheviques
prennent le pouvoir Lénine qui a encore
au fond de lui un soupçon démocratique
organise les élections législatives il
les perd il n'y aura plus jamais
d'élections tout est interdit du jour au
lendemain bivor a fait sur ce thème-là
un livre évidemment qui est aussi
important que les deux vres trois livres
mais en tout cas deux qui viennent de
sortir qui sont exceptionnel le livre de
vivorc qui s'appelle histoire totale de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est chez
Périn avec l'aide du ministère des
armées euh je n'ai pas pu aborder le
quart du 25e du 50e de ce qu'il y a dans
ce livre et c'est exactement la même
chose avec Jean-Luc Barret une multitude
de détails de références de lectures
Berson euh château brillant
qui était quand même stylistiquement
l'une des idoles du général de Gaulle
car plus il était en prison plus il
lisait et et je vous recommande vraiment
ces deux livres celui-là est publié aux
éditions gr j'étais pas passé voy Jean
fabouille comme on dit j'étais ravi de
passer cette demi-heure avec vous
j'espère que les gens vont vous regarder
car ce sont de livres absolument
[Musique]
indispensables